within mathematics extension 2 we've
been looking at mathematical induction
that is of harder varieties than the
kind you had to look at
in mathematics extension 1. the first
example we've had a look at today
is when you have to prove for n
equals and then instead of starting at
one it might be say in this case
five and then six and then seven and
that introduces a couple of extra little
complexities especially when you also
throw in
some of the other cool things we can do
under the nature of proof like
inequalities so
this particular question is somewhat
challenging because it includes both of
those aspects and they've got it played
together
and this solution which i showed earlier
today
relied on the fact that we can begin
with the assumption that's the whole
idea
of mathematical induction we assume that
the statement is true for n equals k
and then we use that as our kind of
foundation for proving that it's true
for n equals k plus one and we went
through this method
and we had a look at you know having to
invoke uh the
particular restriction on what values of
n would work
so since uh it's just here since in this
question n has to be greater than four
when i assume that this statement is
true for n equals k
i give the same restriction to k and
then i have to invoke that restriction
to actually make heads and tails or make
any progress of
the inequality that i'm setting out to
prove now i did mention
and this is why i've labeled this as
method one i did say that this is not
the only way to go about
solving this none of them is going to be
you know i think dramatically easier
than any of the others
but i do want to show you one of the
other techniques that we can use and if
it fits better in your brain makes more
logical sense
then absolutely using that within you
know any task or assessment you have to
do is
totally fine so long as we set it up
properly so
let me outline what method two is first
by reminding you
that if i want to prove uh required to
prove
that a is greater than b one thing is
larger than another
an equivalent statement this is true if
and only
if when you subtract b from both sides
it's still true so i could say a
minus b is greater than zero now this is
a common technique because it's
uh relatively straightforward to prove
that
some algebraic object is going to be
greater than zero because
i can know if if something is positive
it's if it's a log or if it's
squared someone's going real number land
you know you're going
to be positive so we're going to employ
this technique here
so i'm going to call this method 2
and i guess if we named this one here
beginning
with the assumption the n equals k
statement i guess i would call this one
consider the left hand side
take away the right hand side for
the n equals k plus 1 statement so
if you recall the n equals k plus 1
statement
looks like this let me just highlight it
this
is the n equals k plus 1 statement i
can't just say
that 2 to the k plus 1 is greater than k
plus 1 or squared because
i haven't proved that that's true that's
my job but instead what i can say is
well
if i take this left-hand side and
subtract the right-hand side
let's see if i can show that that's
positive i want to show that
this term take away this term is greater
than zero and that will be equivalent
to the result i'm trying to prove so
let's have a go and set out to do that
um the left hand side take away the
right hand side as just stated will be
2 to the k plus 1 minus k
plus 1 or squared okay so when i start
with this as a foundation
uh as with previous proofs by
mathematical induction in extension one
i want to try and manipulate this in
such a way
as to make the inductive hypothesis or
the assumption
i want to make it sort of appear within
my working here now in this case
that is not too difficult to do
remembering that
here is our assumption up here i'll
highlight in a different color here's my
assumption
2 to the k is greater than k squared so
if i can find
2 to the k or k squared in there i can
do some sort of appropriate substitution
i'm going to show you
how i do that for starters let's find
like where's the easiest place to find
one of those terms in the assumption and
i think it's not too difficult to see
that it's going to come from this
exponential term out the front that k
plus 1
i could break that apart to be 2 to the
k
times 2. if that makes sense you know
i'm i've got 2 to the power of 1
and so that's why you're adding these
indices to get k plus 1. i still have
this minus
k plus one hanging out here on the end
okay
now as i stated before what i've now
done even though i only took online
is to rearrange do a very minor
rearrangement to this particular
expression in order to find a term
that's in the assumption and then i can
do some substitution
but you have to be super careful right
i've got an equation here
this thing is equal the left hand side
and the right hand side are identical
but what i'm trying to substitute in
is actually an inequality now we're
quite good at substituting equations
into equations we've been doing it for
years
but how do you substitute an inequality
into an equation
it's not as hard as it looks for example
i think let me just write this off to
the side i think it is fairly
uncontroversial to say
that 5 is greater than 4. so let's just
imagine that this is kind of like our
assumption
right now i can then relate this
assumption
to an equation if i can find you know
either of these terms
within that equation so for instance i
could say that 10
equals 5 plus 5 again a fairly
uncontroversial statement but now what i
can do
is i can take one of these terms like
say this five here
and if i replace it with four think
about what this will mean
if i put five plus four over here
i have replaced this larger object with
a smaller object
so therefore what i end up with on this
second line must obviously be smaller
so this side here is going to be smaller
than this line up over here but
this is equal to the left hand side so
therefore left hand side
10 is going to be bigger than greater
than
5 plus 4. so if you are content to
accept
this logic that you can substitute an
inequality
into an equation by turning it into an
appropriate inequality
then i can do exactly the same thing
here i know that 2 to the k
is bigger than k squared so if
i substitute this k squared
in here i'm now swapping out 2 to the k
for k squared so i'm putting in
something smaller
right i'll finish the rest of it there's
still the 2 there and still this minus k
plus 1 all squared hanging out on the
end
clearly this line here is going to be
smaller
than this line here so therefore i can
say
there's this greater than sign and
everything on the left-hand side is not
actually
changed right now this i i find is the
trickiest concept to wrap your head
around transforming an equation
into a related inequality if it's still
sort of messing with your brain i would
encourage you to return back to this
numerical example
if that convinces you then really we're
doing an identical process here instead
of doing
uh five and four i've substituted
this to the k for this
k squared okay now once i have
established this i can now go to work
and do some of my regular algebraic
manipulation what am i going to get here
this greater than isn't going to change
i've got this 2 k
squared hanging out the front and then
let's expand this before dealing with
the minus sign
that sits out those brackets outside
those brackets
k squared plus 2 k plus 1 there's my
binomial expansion
now i'll apply that minus sign you can
see clearly i'm going to get 2k squared
minus
a single k squared so that leaves me
with k squared out the front
then i'm going to have minus 2k and then
minus
1. okay so let's pause at this moment
and breathe what am i going to do now
well remember what my destination is
what my goal is right
i want to try and show that this left
hand side minus right hand side is
greater than 0.
if this is greater than zero then my
original inequality that i wanted is
actually true so
i want to show this thing is greater
than zero
we've already shown before there are a
bunch of different things that are known
to be greater than zero
the product of two positive numbers will
be positive
the reciprocal of a positive number will
be positive and in this case
the square of a real number i know it
can't be negative it's going to be
greater than or equal
to 0. so how do i make use of that fact
well you can see that this object here
it can't be factorized in its current
form
i can't think of a number a pair of
numbers rather that adds to negative 2
and multiplies to negative 1
but this is not difficult to modify in
such a way that i can factorize it
for example i can say that this is
k squared minus 2k and a thing that i
know how to factorize is
plus 1. you can see here this is not too
difficult to reverse
the expansion you can't just make this
bigger
you know we're trying to we've already
established we can substitute a bigger
thing
for a smaller thing because then you can
link these inequalities but i've just
changed this small thing into a bigger
thing so that's that's no dice this is
not necessarily true
so what i'm going to do is rather than
do an actual change here
i'm going to keep the line the same by
subtracting
2. think about this for a minute right
this
minus 1 whoopsie does he this minus 1
plus 1 minus 2 and this minus 1 are
clearly equal
in values so that's i haven't changed
anything dramatic here but
the reason why this is useful is because
this object out the front here
can be easily factorized it's going to
be k
minus 1 or squared yeah
and then i've got this minus 2 hanging
out on the end there
so what can i do now where can i go with
this
well i'm going to just hit pause on this
i did this before in my previous proof
right i've kind of gotten as far as i
can
in terms of you know some factorization
and algebraic manipulation
i would it'd be really convenient to me
if this whole right hand side was just
something
squared a real number squared um but
it's not i've got a squared and then i'm
subtracting two
um you know if if k were um equal to one
for example
this would be one take away one would be
zero squared minus two that's negative
so it's not necessarily positive
but then maybe you're maybe your cogs of
turning you've realized why
such a situation is impossible k can't
possibly be one
k can't be two or three or four either
because i said right at the beginning
when we introduced k
that k has to be greater than four
that's part of my assumption
so i need to like i i did in this
earlier method i need to invoke this
um this domain restriction as it were on
k
i need to invoke that in order to
complete my proof so let's go ahead
and have a go at that as mentioned i'm
just going to
label this call it inequality 1 and just
hit pause on it and i'm going to say but
hold on a second i know that
k can't just be anything it's greater
than 4.
therefore i can sort of reshape this to
turn into
this object that i have up here on the
right hand side of inequality one
how would i do that well i'm going to
subtract one
because i've got as you can see a k
minus one in there then i'm going to
square it just be careful
when you square this left-hand side
and then square the right-hand side the
inequality
its direction can change because if
you're squaring a negative number
you've just multiplied both sides of
your inequality by a negative we know
that flips around
the inequality's direction i can know
though that i'm not
changing the inequalities direction
because
or since k minus 1 which is the thing
i'm multiplying by uh that's
going to be greater than zero and i'm
getting that from this fact
up above here okay so
i'm almost there i've got k minus 1 all
squared on the left hand side but i
actually need
k minus 1 all squared minus 2. so
therefore i'm going to say
let's subtract 2 from both sides that
gives me
7. and this inequality i can do a
straight substitution into you can see
this
is the right hand side of inequality
one so i can say right linking
to inequality one i'm actually going to
give that an extra line just so you can
see this is a different sort of
direction of logic that i'm going in
i'm going to say all of this stuff is
still here
on the left hand most part of my
inequality
and then this part over here goes on the
right hand side
there we go so this is bigger than this
but i just established that this
is bigger than seven so what can i say
well
two to the k plus one minus k plus one
or squared that's greater than seven
but seven is positive so that's going to
be greater than zero
uh i've got 2 to the k plus 1 minus
k plus 1 all squared is greater than 0
and this was the situation i wanted this
is the
a minus b is greater than 0 situation
that i was seeking
all along so finally i can just restore
this to
the left on the left and the right
on the right as required
and uh from here i think you're good to
go we've just proven
the k plus 1 case is true provided the k
case is true um and you still had to do
you know some of this work right
you kind of you cannot get through this
proof without somehow referring to the
fact that k
has to be bigger than four because n has
to be bigger than four if you don't use
that fact
um you can't prove this possibly so i
hope that makes sense
if you like this left hand side take
away right hand side way
of approaching these questions then go
for it but i will say
the the more tools that you can be
comfortable um
working with the more tools you have
access to in your toolbox
the greater variety of problems you'll
be able to solve